tiens l'actualité de ces dernières
semaines et la présence militaire russe
en géorgie a relancé la notion de guerre
froide un concept qui était encore bien
réelle à la fin des années 80 de monde à
l'époque s'opposer voici ce soir l'un
des vestiges de l'ex allemagne de l'est
le bunker den driessche au necker ancien
leader de la rda un abri antiatomique
qui vient de s'ouvrir au public grand
format signé jérôme bomy et brice
boussouar à une quarantaine de
kilomètres de berlin bien caché dans la
forêt l'entrée du plus grand abri
antiatomique jamais creusé dans un pays
de l'est de l'europe
anciennement communistes 7500 mètres
carrés de salles souterraines
construite entre 1978 et 83 une démesure
à l'image de la paranoïa qui régnait
pendant la guerre froide
surnommé bunker honecker il était
destiné à l'ancien dirigeant est
allemand et aux membres de son conseil
national de défense dans ce bunker
aujourd'hui ouverts au public
on peut découvrir la porte de deux
tonnes qui permettait d'accéder au sas
de sécurité en cas d'attaqué nucléaire
toutes personnes rentrant dans l'abri
devait suivre la ligne rouge pour passer
sous les douches de décontamination
les seuls d'importance vitale bénéficie
d'un système de suspension que les
visiteurs sont invités à tester et qui
permet de résister un impact nucléaire
ah oui c'est une construction unique
c'est un chef-d'oeuvre techniques
d'ingénierie qu'ils ont réalisés ici les
visiteurs ici des allemands de l'est
sont en revanche écoeuré quand ils
apprennent qu'il a fallu 85 mille tonnes
de béton pour l'édifice vous imaginez un
télévision alors que nous allions très
peu de matériaux à l'époque c'était très
dur de trouver du ciment et pourtant
voilà ce qu'ils construisaient 400
personnes pouvaient survivre ici avec de
la nourriture pour 15 jours dans la
salle de commande du make-up cette
manette permettait de choisir le mode
d'aération de la route la position 3 est
enclenchée en cas d'explosion nucléaire
ce qui permet de rendre hermétique la
construction pendant 36 heures et
d'assurer l'alimentation électrique
uniquement par source interne à côté de
ce qui devait être le bureau de necker
sa chambre à coucher et il aurait même
disposer d'un studio télévision pour
s'adresser aux survivants à la surface
cet indice il y avait une caméra comme
ultime possibilité de rassembler le
peuple et de lui redonner espoir en tout
cas tous ceux qui veulent se donner des
frissons de guerre froide doivent se
dépêcher car ce bunker sera fermée aux
visites à la phantom